mai trovate bella si no
certo come sai io credo che non ci sia
dei cantanti ma si scusa lei e marina la
mia ragazza piacere serena
ciao andiamo a fare gioco no per quale
motivo poi ancora questo 13 cocco ma di
più va via subito chi cazzo è mia madre
volevate no scusa dove stai andando
vestito così quella tuta lo sai
benissimo che chiude esposto vedere solo
io giusto e quei jeans dai fa il vago
che volevo sì ma cambia immagine profilo
va bene bene per amore come stai
ciao amore bene tutto posso dove sei
sono un balcone di casa di andrea visto
un nuovo signore perché ha tentennato e
la nostra pò di sè me non andava più
bene
e lui e se sì per quale motivo non
meritavo invito subito che non volevi e
adesso voglio venire ok cazzo è questa
voce di donna che sentono un balcone ci
sono centomila e poi non ci provino più
no io ho trovato una conversazione come
access abominevole capire se tutto va
bene ha capito io sono grafica ne vado a
bruciare capiti vicenda è finita c'è ma
si impara che glielo dico lui è già ci
ho messo duramente per trovare la sua
fatto di facebook se glielo dico cambia
password sono rovinata chi cazzo è stato
il tono di merda che ti ride a tutte le
foto
senti bassa conti più di meglio per me
in mezzo ad un ossessione non è che non
mi fido di te amore io non mi fido
teatri ma che vanno in giro ma capisci
di giorno che cambierò
e adesso chi cazzo è pale ale ale